-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
We're about to play a game
called "What's Behind Me?"
My partner tonight is
a talented actress
and successful entrepreneur,
who is the founder of
The Honest Company.
Please give it up for
the one-and-only Jessica Alba!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, come on!
Thank you for being here.
It's so good to see you.
-Thank you for having me.
-Here's how the game works.
Jessica and I will take turns
facing our backs to the curtain.
Behind the
curtain will be something
neither of us have seen before.
It could be
people, objects, anything.
Once the curtain opens
and you pick up your card,
you have 45 seconds to try to
get the other person
to guess what's behind them.
You can say anything
you want or use gestures.
You just can't say any of
the words on your card.
Jessica,
you'll be guessing first.
Let's get into position.
-Okay.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, Jessica.
-That was scary.
-I know.
It's kind of fun, right?
Jessica, let's open the curtain
and see what's behind you.
-Okay.
-Alright, here we go.
Okay. Alright, here we go.
Ready?
Okay. Alright,
it's a Dr. Seuss character.
-A cat.
-The other one.
A holiday.
-A fish?
-Yes.
-Fish?
-No.
-Holiday.
-Ugh!
A dog?
-He stole Christmas.
-Oh, The Grinch.
-Yeah.
[ Ding ]
A movie with Julia Roberts where
she finds herself in Italy.
-"Eat Pray Love."
-That's correct.
And it's in a transportation
device that --
It floats in the -- It floats.
And you're in a basket.
-Oh, a hot-air balloon.
-That's correct.
We did it right there.
The Grinch reading
"Eat Pray Love"
in a hot-air balloon.
Now look at -- See the --
-Oh, my God.
-Wow!
-It's real.
-Oh, my God.
I don't like that Grinch
looking at me.
That was very odd.
Well, he's enjoying the book.
He's thinking.
-I had no idea it was going to
be, like, a real thing.
-Oh, yeah,
these are real things.
Yeah.
[ Both laugh ]
Alright, here we go.
Now it is my turn to guess.
-Okay.
-Let's rotate the stage.
-Alright, here we go.
-Do I look in the --
-Not yet. Not yet.
-Oh, oh, okay.
-Once we get settled in here.
I'm getting ready. Alright.
Okay, Jessica,
grab that blue card,
and when the curtains open,
time starts
when you start talking.
Now let's see what's behind me.
♪♪
-Oh, wow!
It's...
-Okay.
-So, it's a -- looking for --
The people that look for
treasure, and they're on...
-Treasure hunters.
-...a ship.
-Oh.
-And they might have, like, a --
-Pirates?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-And the pirate is washing hair.
-Okay, it's a hairstylist.
Hair dyeing.
-Washing hair.
A pirate is washing his --
-What is it when you
wash your hair?
-Cleaning. Showering. Bathing.
-You wash your hair with...
-Shampoo. Using shampoo.
-Yes.
-So, a pirate --
his hair with --
You put it on --
It's with chips and it's --
-Guacamole?
-But the other thing.
-Salsa.
No.
-It's --
There's different types of it.
It's a gooey orange substance.
-Cheez Whiz. Velveeta.
[ Buzzer ]
Or nacho cheese!
[ Ding ]
-Yeah.
-So a pirate is shampooing
with nacho cheese.
[ Dinging ]
-Yes.
-Shampooing --
♪♪
Oh, gross!
Alright. Alright. Very nice.
Yikes! Oh, my gosh.
-I just feel like
I got distracted
with all of the action
that was happening.
-That's something
you can't unsee, really.
-Right.
-But you did it. We got that.
See? We're good partners.
We got that one, right?
We got the points for that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright.
It is your turn to guess.
Let's rotate. Here we go.
-I mean, wanted to say, "queso,"
but I felt like
that would have been cheating.
-Yeah, it would have
been cheating.
No, it's perfect.
Alright, let's see
what's behind you.
♪♪
Okay.
Okay, it is --
It's a performance artist
that you would see in France.
-A mime.
-Yes. Thank you.
It is -- He's wearing a form of
transportation that --
-A skateboard.
Roller skates.
-Yes, the other one.
-Skateboard, roller skates --
Rollerblades.
-Yes. And he's --
-A mime...
-Yes.
-...with Rollerblades.
-That's right.
And a famous potato chip,
but it's in a tube.
-Oh, yeah. Frito-Lay.
Um...
Aah!
-And it's --
The guy's got a little bow tie.
-Yeah.
Pringles!
-Yes! Yes!
[ Dinging ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
-What was that?!
-A mime with their hand
stuck in Pringles can.
Good job. Sorry, mime.
Very good job.
Oh, my gosh. Fantastic.
-What was that?
-He ended weird. Okay.
I don't know what was
happening at the end.
We'll blur it out
when we air it.
Okay, it is time
for the final round.
Let's rotate the stage.
Here we go.
Alright, here we go.
♪♪
♪ Mmmm ♪
Ready, Jessica?
-Yeah.
-Now let's see what's behind me.
-Okay, let's see.
♪♪
Oh!
-These reactions you make are
like, "Oh, my gosh!"
-I just --
-Okay.
-Okay, so, it's a clown
that is part of a food chain,
and they have --
-Ronald McDonald.
-Yes.
And he is sitting in
a -- oh -- spa.
-Oh. Oh.
-Another word for a spa
that's outside.
-It's a steam -- steam room.
Sauna.
-Spa. Spa.
-Spa.
-With water.
-Spa with water would be --
I have no -- A spa with water.
A hot tub?
-Mm-hmm.
-Okay.
-Ronald McDonald in a hot tub.
-Mm-hmm.
-Alright, this sounds like
my bachelor party.
-Throwing -- throwing -- It's a
game that you throw at a --
-Paddle ball? Darts?
-Yes.
[ Ding ]
-What?!
That was my bachelor party.
Let me see this thing.
Oh, my God!
That is unbelievable.
Well-done. Oh, my gosh.
Again, things you can't unsee.
Jessica Alba, everybody!